TODAY.
>> BUT WE DID SEE JUSTICE.
THANK YOU FOR TAKE REPORT.
FOR MORE REACTION, I'M JOINED BY
WANDA COOPER JONES AND HER
ATTORNEY.
WANDA AND LEE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
OUR HEARTS CONTINUE TO GO OUT TO
YOU.
YOU SAID THAT BACK THIS 2020,
YOU NEVER THOUGHT THAT THIS DAY
WOULD COME.
TODAY YOUR SON'S KILLERS WERE
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO YOU?
>> IT MEANS A LOT.
AND IT MEANS THAT MY PRAYERS HAS
BEEN ANSWERED.
EARLY BACK IN THE CASE BACK IN
2020, 74 DAYS WITHOUT AN ARREST.
AND WE FINALLY WAS ABLE TO GO
THROUGH A LENGTHY TRIAL AND GET
JUSTICE FOR HIM.
>> AND SO WHAT WENT THROUGH YOUR
MIND WHEN YOU HEARD THE JUDGE
SAY GUILTY FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME?
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE RELIEF WHAT
YOU WERE FEELING AT THAT MOMENT?
>> AGAIN, WE WAITED 74 DAYS
WITHOUT AN ARREST.
AND THEN TO HEAR THAT THE
ACCUSED MURDERERS WERE ACTUALLY
FOUND GUILTY, THAT WAS HUGE.
WE FINALLY GOT THE JUSTICE FOR
AHMAUD ARBERY OIGTHAT HE DESERV.
>> AND KAMALA HARRIS RELEASED A
STATEMENT SAYING THAT THESE
VERDICTS SENT AN IMPORTANT
MESSAGE, BUT SHE IS TAKING ISSUE
WITH THE DEFENSE TEAM AND SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT THEY MADE,
SOME OF THE HORRENDOUS COMMENTS
THAT THEY MADE DURING THE TRIAL.
WE CAN PUT IT ON SCREEN.
SHE SAYS THAT THE DEFENSE
COUNSEL CHOSE TO SET A TONE THAT
CAST THE ATTENDANCE OF MINISTERS
AT THE TRIAL AS INTIMIDATION AND
DEHUMANIZE A YOUNG BLACK MAN
WITH RAPIST TROPES.
WHAT DO THINK, IS THIS VERDICT
PROOF THAT IT BACKFIRED ON THE
DEFENSE?
WHAT IS YOUR SENSE OF IT?
>> CERTAINLY RELIEF TO HEAR VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA STEP IN AND SAY
THAT YOU WON'T CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT BLACK CHILDREN AND BLACK
MEN IN THIS WAY.
WHAT THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY DID
WENT BEYOND OF WHAT WE EXPECT IN
TERMS OF PROFESSIONALISM.
EVERYONE IS SBIENTITLED TO A DE.
BUT TO GO OUT OF THEIR WAY TO
USE TERMS LIKE DIRTY TOENAILS
AND TO ATTACK AHMAUD PERSONALLY
KNOWING THAT HIS FAMILY WAS
SITTING IN THE COURTROOM, THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT GOT UNDER OUR
SKIN A BIT.
AND I CERTAINLY THINK THAT IT
BACKFIRED.
WE'RE GLAD TO HEAR THAT THE JURY
WASN'T GOING TO BE FOOLED BY THE
INVITATION TO MAKE THIS CASE
ABOUT AHMAUD'S BLACKNESS AND
SOME STEREOTYPES ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF BEING BLACK AND MALE
IN AMERICA.
>> AND WANDA, I WAS WONDERING
ABOUT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS.
>> REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEY SAID
ABOUT AHMAUD, HOW DIRTY HIS
TOENAILS WERE, WHO CAME OUT TO
SUPPORT THIS GRIEVING FAMILY, AT
THE END OF THE DAY, ALL WE
WANTED WAS JUST FOR AHMAUD AND
THAT IS WHAT WE GOT.
>> AND YOU THANKED EVERYONE WHO
PRAYED FOR THIS VERDICT.
CAN YOU DESCRIBE HOW YOUR FAITH
HAS CARRIED YOU THROUGH ALL OF
THIS?
>> LIKE I SAID IN THE VERY
BEGINNING, GOD HAS NEVER FAILED
ME.
HE'S NEVER FAILED ME.
AND I KNEW THAT HE WOULD NOT
FAIL ME NOW.
SO I KNEW THAT WE WOULD GET A
GUILTY VERDICT.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHEN, BUT I KNEW
THAT IT WOULD COME EVENTUALLY.
>> AND LEE, I'LL BE SPEAKING TO
MARTIN LUTHER KING III IN THE
NEXT HOUR.
I WONDER IF YOU FEEL IN THE
WORDS OF HIS FATHER THAT THE
LONG ARC OF THE MORAL UNIVERSE
BENT A LITTLE MORE TOWARD
JUSTICE TODAY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, WE WERE CERTAINLY
INSPIRED TO SEE REVEREND MARTIN
LUTHER KING III SUPPORTING THIS
FAMILY, CONTINUING THE LEGACY OF
HIS FATHER.
THE MORAL ARC IS LONG BUT IT
DOESN'T BEND ON ITS OWN, IT
TAKES FIGHT BEING MOTHERS LIKE
THE ONE I'M SITTING NEXT TO THAT
I HAVE THE REAL HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO REPRESENT, YOU
KNOW, THESE THINGS DON'T HAPPEN
IN A VACUUM.
BUT IT TOOK SLEEPLESS NIGHTS, A
LOT OF TIME ON HER KNEES IN
PRAYER AND SHE GOT UP AND MADE
IT HAPPEN.
AND SO THE REASON -- AND IT IS
TRUE FOR DR. KING AS WELL, THE
REASON HIS MINISTRY, HIS CAREER
WAS SO SUCCESSFUL IS BECAUSE HE
WAS SUPPORTED BY BLACK WOMEN,
MOTHERS WHO FOUGHT TO CHANGE THE
UNITED STATES.
AND WANDA CONTINUES THAT LEGACY.
>> AND WANDA, WHAT IS YOUR
MESSAGE TO OTHER MOTHERS OF
BLACK CHILDREN WHO ARE WATCHING
RIGHT NOW AND FEARING THAT THEIR
OWN CHILD MAY NEVER GET JUSTICE?
AND I WONDER IF YOU'VE THOUGHT
AT ALL ABOUT OTHER MOTHERS WHO
HAVE BEEN IN YOUR CIRCUMSTANCE
WHO HAVE HAD YOUNG MEN WHO WERE
SONS KILLED BY POLICE IN CASES
WHERE THERE WASN'T JUSTICE.
AND I JUST WONDER WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE ON THAT.
>> YES, I OFTEN THINK OF MOTHERS
LIKE BREONNA TAYLOR'S MOM OR
JEFFERSON IN TEXAS WHICH THAT IS
GETTING READY TO GO INTO TRIAL.
BUT A LOT OF THESE FAMILIES
DON'T GET JUSTICE.
AND MY MESSAGE IS DON'T GIVE UP,
KEEP PUSHING, KEEP FIGHTING.
>> AND WE'RE A DAY BEFORE
THANKSGIVING.
AHMAUD WON'T BE WITH YOU AT THE
THANKSGIVING DAY TABLE TOMORROW.
WHAT THOUGHTS GO THROUGH YOUR
MIND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
YOU WILL BE EXPERIENCING
TOMORROW ON THIS THANKSGIVING?
YOU HAVE TO BE THANKFUL FOR
JUSTICE, BUT YOUR SON WON'T BE
THERE.
CAN YOU TALK TO US ABOUT THAT?
>> THIS IS THE SECOND
THANKSGIVING THAT WE'LL BE
WITHOUT AHMAUD.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, THIS IS
THE FIRST THANKSGIVING THAT
WE'LL HAVE FOR JUSTICE WITH
AHMAUD.
SO I'M TAKING TOMORROW AS A VERY
THANKFUL DAY AND I GIVE ALL
PRAISES TO GOD.
>> WHAT KIND OF MAN WAS HE, WHAT
SHOULD PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT YOUR
SON?
>> AHMAUD WAS LOVE.
HE WAS A KIND YOUNG MAN.
AND HE DEFINITELY DIDN'T DESERVE
TO LOSE HIS LIFE IN THE WAY THAT
HE DID.
>> AND LEE, THE DEFENDANTS WHO
HAVE NOW BEEN CONVICTED OF
MURDER, THEY ARE ALSO FACING
FEDERAL HATE CRIME CHARGES.
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SEND AND
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT FROM THAT
TRIAL?
DO YOU STILL WANT TO SEE THAT
>> WE'RE CERTAINLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE SENTENCING PHASE
OF THIS CASE.
OUR UNDERSTANDING AS EXPLAINED
TO US BY THE PROSECUTORS OF
GEORGIA LAW IS THAT EACH OF
THESE MEN ARE FACING LIFE
SENTENCES.
THE REST OF THEIR LIFE IN
PRISON.
WE THINK THAT IS APPROPRIATE.
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
FEDERAL PROSECUTION.
WE HAVE A TRIAL DATE FOR JANUARY
20th WHERE WE'LL BE DOWN IN
SAVANNAH PURSUING THESE MEN ON
HATE CRIME CHARGES.
AND, YOU KNOW, INJUSTICE IS A
TEAM SPORT.
SO JACKIE JOHNSON IS FACING
CRIMINAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE'LL DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> SHOULD AMERICANS TONIGHT HAVE
MORE FAITH IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK THAT WHAT WE
WITNESSED WAS AN ANOMALY.
ALL THE MEDIA AND PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD ARE STOPPING TO SAY
OH, MY GOD, THEY GOT JUSTICE IN
THIS CASE.
SO THAT IS NOT A GOOD SIGN, THAT
PEOPLE THINK THAT CASE THAT IS
OPEN AND OBVIOUS, ONE RECORDED
ON A BRIGHT SUNDAY DAY AND JUST
LAST YEAR, THAT IT WAS A BIG
QUESTION MARK.
AND THERE WAS A STRONG DOUBT
THAT WE WOULD GET JUSTICE.
AND SO IT REPRESENTS HOW FAR WE
HAVE TO GO.
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW GETTING
HERE WASN'T EASY, THAT WE HAD TO
DIG THROUGH PROSECUTORS BEFORE
WE LANDED ON SOMEONE WHO WAS
WILLING DO THEIR JOB.
AND SO IT TELLS US WHERE WE ARE,
BUT THAT WHERE WE ARE IS NOT
WHERE WE OUGHT TO BE.
AND SO THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
ROAD AHEAD OF US.
>> L